so
in a broad sense before we talk about
newer evolution
do you see evolutionary computation as
more effective than deep learning a
certain context
machine learning broadly speaking maybe
even
supervised machine learning i don't know
if you want to draw any kind of lines
and distinctions and
borders where they rub up against each
other kind of thing or one is more
effective than the other in the current
state of things
yes of course they are very different
and they address different kinds of
problems and
the deep learning has been really
successful in domains where we have a
lot of data
and that means not just data about
situations but also what the right
answers were
so labeled examples or they might be
predictions maybe better prediction
where the data itself
becomes labels what happened what the
weather was today and what will
it will be tomorrow
so they are very effective deep learning
methods on on that kind of tasks
but there are other kinds of tasks where
we don't really know what the right
answer is
uh game playing for instance but many
robotics tasks and
uh actions in the world decision making
and actual practical applications like
treatments and health care
or investment in stock market many tasks
are like that
we will we don't know and we'll never
know what the optimal answers were
and there you need different kinds of
approaches reinforcement learning is one
of those
reinforcement learning comes from
biology as well
agents learn during their lifetime they
eat berries and sometimes they get sick
and then they don't
and get stronger and then that's how you
learn
and evolution is also a mechanism like
that
by the different time scale because you
have a population not an individual
during its lifetime but an entire
population
as a whole can discover um what works
and there you can afford individuals
that don't work out
they will you know everybody dies and
you have a next generation and it will
be better than the previous one
so that's that's the big difference
between these methods they apply to
different kinds of problems
um and um in particular
there's often a comparison that's kind
of interesting and important between
reinforcement learning and evolutionary
computation
and initially um reinforcement learning
was about
individual learning during the lifetime
and evolution is more
engineering you don't care about the
lifetime you don't care about all the
individuals that are tested you only
care about the final result
the last one the best candidate that
evolution produced
in that sense they also apply to
different kinds of problems
and now that boundary is starting to
blur a bit you can use evolution
as an online method and reinforcement
learning to create engineering solutions
but
that's still roughly the distinction uh
and um from the point of view what
algorithm you want to use if you have
something where there is a cost for
every trial reinforcement learning might
be your choice
now if you have a domain where you can
use a surrogate perhaps
so you don't have much of a cost for
trial
and you want to have surprises you want
to explore more broadly
then this population-based method is
perhaps a better choice because you you
can try things out that you wouldn't
afford when you're doing reinforcement
you